[Music]
maybe more than any other cities Seattle
Washington seems to represent what
America is becoming Amazon Microsoft
Starbucks are all based in the city or
its suburbs Jeff Bezos the richest man
in the world lives there but along with
unfathomable wealth there is also
desperate poverty and widespread
degradation Seattle's homeless
population is surging the city is
suffocating under garbage produced by
hundreds of homeless camps rather than
take action the City Council has enabled
the problem and even recently suggested
the garbage is really left by
middle-class residents who are trying to
frame the homeless local news broadcast
recently grabbed national headlines by
warning that Seattle is dying the city
becomes unlivable for regular families
for day three of our homeless in America
series our producer Charlie Cooper
visited Seattle to get an up-close look
at what is happening there Seattle's
homelessness crisis is deeply connected
to the city's drug crisis that's what we
learned we visited this sprawling
encampment off of Interstate five it's
really sad Washington native Eric Nelson
is homeless he lives in a nearby shelter
where he's undergoing methadone
treatment he came to this encampment to
visit friends do you think drugs are one
of the primary drivers of homelessness I
think mental health is you know health
is the foundation of you know a lot of
you know addiction and other things
mental health and addiction are clearly
problems when we arrived on a Wednesday
afternoon the residents were cleaning up
their camp
it was littered with syringes how many
people would you say like it's a
percentage I think I here are doing
drugs I would say a good 60% you know
that's maybe a little short but
benefited
really it's really easy even outside the
i5 camp there was evidence of a drug
epidemic throughout Seattle near a
shelter downtown we found this poster
warning drug users about the dangers of
fentanyl Seattle is a kind of mecca for
drug addicts Washington State legalized
marijuana and Seattle's police force as
a program that refers some low-level
drug criminals to social services
instead of jail like san francisco
seattle city government has essentially
decriminalized quality-of-life crimes
misdemeanor citations have plummeted
since 2009 hey guys
the consequence will see it for yourself
here's a video of a man passed out in a
popular park this picture shows you
urine on a public staircase near City
Hall
this picture shows human waste a few
steps above that homelessness became
more visible as Seattle's leaders became
more lenient on petty crime because of
their liberal attitudes in the mild
climate the city is a magnet for
vagrants Nelson thinks most of the
people at the i5 camp didn't grow up in
the area probably about more than half
probably not from Seattle homelessness
is complicated drugs aren't the only
cause take a look at this picture of
people living in broken-down RVs in the
background
the world headquarters of Starbucks like
most of the west coast
Seattle's economic boom has not been
distributed evenly not close when weight
is at the low end of the economic
spectrum failed to keep up with the
rising cost of living you wind up with a
place where people living in their cars
are flanked by billionaires like Jeff
Bezos and Bill Gates so what causes
homelessness many things drug addiction
economic hardship illness but one thing
that everyone living on the street seems
to have in common
broken families in the case of Eric
Nelson he hasn't seen his family since
he was 16 years old we just kind of
split
we didn't really have too much in common
so I just parted ways when I was 16 and
then I ran out of money I ran out of
everything and so I was homeless isn't
just big cities suffering from a
homelessness epidemic tomorrow night as
our series continues we'll take a look
at homelessness in the college town of
Eugene Oregon amazing what's happening